you know when it comes to effects of
movies these days we've pretty much Seen
It All right we have like giant LED
screens that we're shooting on we have
Lions talking to each other but when it
comes to one basic effect we still do it
the same old tired way bone breaking
go to a cutaway hide the swap to the
prop then cut back out to the wide and
do the bone break break it baby
ah so Scott Atkins you know the action
star Scott Atkins and he's producing a
movie and he was wondering if we wanted
to do a shot for the film now not just
visual effects but to conceptualize and
design the entire shot I've always
wanted to do a good bone break and this
is my chance to do it in an actual movie
so let's go figure it out
[Music]
trying to brainstorm ideas
so when Scott Atkins was here I offered
to do a VFX shot for his next film he
was really chill about and said yeah
let's do it so Scott put me in touch
with George and Harry who are the two
directors in this film so I asked them
if I could finally try doing this wacky
bone break effect I've always been
wanting to do and they said yeah go for
it so cool but now I need to come up
with a way to do this really unique shot
you know a bone break effect with no
cuts and no like real CGI I need to make
sure it's doable I need to make sure
it's good how do you actually shoot it
and send it to the directors to get
their approval so yeah I'm gonna grab
Matt and Jordan and we're gonna try
making this because I have I have a way
that we might be able to pull us off
what we're gonna be showing up here is
it's just really a proof of concept for
this visual effects shot and action slam
Michael throws a punch chamber block and
then Scott grabs his arms grab an elbow
at least he's got pull the arm around
backwards the point where like you know
it's bent around the corner snap snap
boom
good so now that we've got a performance
that I like I take I took my frame here
Jordan has just broken Matt's arm I'm
going to line everything up here to this
frame for the prosthetic break see that
exact spot foreign
all right you need to bring it right to
here so as Jordan breaks his arm she
wipes across it and then she moves back
and reveals the broken elbow we've wiped
to a different shot reviews a prosthetic
arm because everything to the right of
her hands is going to be replaced with
the prosthetic arm but to the left of
her hands I'm keeping the real hands so
I need to have it line up so that I can
match it underneath her hands rolling in
three two one action
that was awesome okay you guys nailed it
Saran is the resident expert on bone
breaking um it's wondering if you could
take a look at this what you got Nico
at first I thought I was like oh wow
okay so you just got like a dummy arm
there but then you played the full shot
and I was like
excuse me wow
it shows off the effect like where does
it even switch I think this will get the
Scott Atkins seal of approval so
everybody here seems to like the clip I
like the clip the directors like the
clip so now we're gonna do it just one
big problem they're on the opposite side
of the globe and I'm right here in Los
Angeles so I have to build an
instructional video to tell them exactly
how to do this really pretty complicated
effect
and I gotta hope it just all works out
so fingers crossed
[Music]
so they just finished shooting the movie
and we got the footage and I'm ready to
begin working on my shot but the
director shot another fatality for
another fight scene that they really
need help with and they asked if they
could do it and I said heck yes because
there's one person here who's perfect
for that job so I just got to take a
look at the plate that I'm going to be
doing this effect on essentially the
effect that I need to create is Scott is
pushing a skewer through the back of
this woman's head which pushes out her
eye and essentially I'm going to create
a CGI on the end of a skewer that
dangles in front of camera for a while
so slow what's wrong with you look I've
been looking up a lot of Gore for this
eyeball skewer shot and I cannot end
back up on those FBI lists I won't have
it and that's why I use expressvpn look
if you're not using a VPN the reality is
you're sending a postcard to the entire
internet anyone can see it all the
peepers and creepers got their eyes on
your stuff you gotta wrap it up in a
nice tight envelope something people
can't see through that's what expressvpn
provides look at these pictures
you can't see them why because we're
illustrating expressvpn with gaussian
blur shown without expressvpn I'm
kidding we can't I don't think we can do
that we shouldn't do that there's never
any buffering it won't slow you down I
can load up all the nasty images that I
need to that I need to notice that I
didn't say want to it is impossible for
the expressvpn servers to keep any log
of what it is that you were doing when
you were online poof never happened look
there's a reason why expressvpn is rated
as the number one VPN Provider by CNET
by The Verge and there's others look it
up dude but use expressvpn and with
expressvpn you can browse from almost
any country right 94 to be exact they
think you're in Portugal well guess what
I'm a Vietnam baby come get me don't
when the US Netflix removes the American
office from streaming you can use
expressvpn to just tell Netflix you're
coming from the UK where they still have
it and you can continue watching the
second best version of the office find
out how you can get three months of
expressvpn by visiting expressvpn.com
Corridor or clicking the link Link in
the description below so now that I've
used expressvpn to mask my Gore research
for this video I'm going to head back
upstairs and put the finishing touches
on this eyeball shot
all right so I just got the footage from
the shoot and these are the two plates
they needed to film the version of
pretending to break the guy's arm and
the other version of the guy does the
motion like his arm is broken and that's
it now it's really important these are
all lined up correctly so the first
thing I got to do is I gotta cut Scott
out because he's going to be on top of a
lot of the footage here the next thing I
gotta do is I have to make a Clean Plate
because the clown has to be removed from
one shot kind of stuck to the other shot
the tricky thing here is I cut them out
I need to be worried about these Shadows
so the hand here that's to the left of
Scott's hands is from the take with
Scott but the wrist and the arms to the
right of Scott's hands is from the take
where there's no Scott and so there's no
Shadow there so I have to fix that but
they line it up really well like I
barely have to do any like fudging of
the image to make it work there like the
transition Flawless you can't tell that
it's a separate take filmed at a
different time underneath Scott as he
passes over the clown all right this
shot's done let's show it to the
directors for the very first time and
see if it's at all at the Quality level
that they're expecting for a movie hi
Nico
um so we are just about to look at the
poker arm brake kit that you've been
working on uh really excited to see it
and this is the first course in the
first part you've sent so we're going to
look at it we actually sort of uh see
what think and there there's some nice
benefits
like the Stitch between I can't see even
going forward coming back it's like
perfect that's seamless so anything on
notes here is a little bit of uh Scott's
Roto around his nose and by his hair
there there's just a little bit yeah
yeah maybe a little bit of a bit flicker
on Scott's arm fist on hold him as well
if you made it yeah really nice job
thank you very much thank you very much
very very useful notes I love getting
critiques critiques from people that
know what they're talking about are very
rare and few and far between them every
time you get the chance for one you
should treasure it so I like that aspect
of it but that doesn't mean it's not
nerve-wracking I think when they see
you're a shot they're gonna be like holy
moly this is rad well we hope we don't
know we're gonna have to find out V1 of
this effect is complete I'm very happy
with the results I basically use certain
high points of contrast on her face as
references for the tracking once the
camera was solved and taken care of the
fun part began and that that is the
simulation part I was able to just stick
a skewer onto that geometry that's now
moving at that point I just needed to
animate it actually coming through the
back of the head and we had our skewer
taken care of now for the eye basically
I took an actual eye model and I
fractured it up I chopped it into a
bunch of different pieces and then I
stuck those pieces back together with
constraints and I stuck those pieces
over the actual moving and animating
skewer so the eye in essence was
sticking to that skewer I also needed to
take care of the muscles in the eye and
just like I attached the eyepieces to
the skewer I attached the muscles to the
eye so once we had everything stitched
together everything is attached to
everything else then you have to
simulate the eye itself and this is
where you can kind of get artistic with
it how jiggly do we want the eye to be
and so I wanted it to almost have like
fractured the pieces like if you drop a
hard-boiled egg or something it's so
disgusting the final result is something
that's incredibly visceral to watch
which I think was the goal of the
directors or I certainly hope it was the
goal of the directors because that's
what I did so I guess we'll find out huh
hey guys uh guys so yeah we've just been
sent the clip for uh eyeball skewer so
that's uh
oh god oh that is pretty pretty gruesome
good work great okay well that's a huge
relief well now they're Switching gears
you can tell yeah now they're going to
go into analytics mode yeah the
directors have kicked in one thing I was
just thinking was I love the idea a bit
more
Ryan just almost riding the screen and
maybe you know kind of rack Focus to the
eye a little bit you know so we want to
kind of get that feeling this eyeballs
up right in his face you know so the
other thing is the the shot that comes
after this
is the shop where we see Dante get
covered we had a blood pump just pumping
blood which is supposed to be coming
from the ice up here yeah I forgot about
that continuity that that is on me 100
let's take a quick look
yeah so that's uh that's a spray
that's a full-on spray dude the version
that I did right now it's it's lacking
any blood spray it's more just the
actual eye poke itself so that that's a
very good note and I should have I
should have considered that we love what
you've done
um so far so thank you guys thank you
Nico thank you Jordan really appreciate
it yeah I Gotta Give Them perhaps for
knowing the continuity so thoroughly
that they're not looking at the edit
they're just looking at one effect shot
out of context like
actually that's based on the other shot
at this endpoint so this needs this in
the out Point yeah like these guys are
in it so we just got the notes back on
these shots and there are two major
things that we need to take care of uh
the blood splatter that is going to be
hitting the lens so that we have
continuity between this shot and the
following shot but first and foremost we
have to take care of the focus and
hopefully Nico is able to address his
feedback and with that we just have to
sit back and wait to see if these
effects make the cut in the theater
Jordan I got a special treat for you
we've been working hard on these shots
we got all the feedback from the
directors and I reached out to Scott
himself to see if you could take a
little bit of his precious time to take
a look at the shots with us and tell us
what he thinks obviously the director's
approving it is is a big thing but the
person who put your name forward in the
first place that's very important that
they're happy having kind of you know
gone out on the limb for you so it's
important that Scott likes this uh I am
both both nervous but but excited too
how you doing Scott I'm good Nico how
are you mate I'm doing good man Scott we
want to hear we want to hear what you
think how did the shot turn out did it
achieve your expectations at all I'm
gonna play it real quick here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
well first of all I want to give myself
a big pass on the back as producer but
having the idea to mine the talents of
corridor courage it's absolutely
incredible quack quack there it is and
he looks at it and he's still waggling
his fingers no hidden Cuts we sort of
explained a few scenarios didn't we and
you gave us some options specifically
with the arm break I mean he pretty much
came up with that whole thing yourself
you know that was like we added it into
the choreography because you said hey
guys what about this we've got an idea
and of course we've seen how you've done
it now we're thinking well [ __ ] man we
can't do a worse job than them because
they're gonna look really bad now I
gotta say like in most Productions
usually like the effects team doesn't
get to approach like the producers and
director and be like hey I want to do
this shot can you guys write it into the
movie when I see bones break in movies
it's usually you know it has a lot of
impact except so often they just cheated
with a cut and I really just wanted to
make it all one cohesive shot like it
totally sells I'm glad it turned out as
great as it did but yeah you explained
everything roughly to us let's take a
look at the the eyeball skewer shot
it's just it's just amazing the way the
way it's sort of wobbling like that I
mean it looks so realistic you know I
like how the eyeball is kind of obscured
by the blood it actually kind of makes
it hit harder I wanted to ask did we
rack Focus to where the eyeball would be
or was that something you guys did no no
that was done in post that was done in
post oh brilliant it did feel a bit
weird or foreign when it wasn't the
focal point obviously you know if if the
DP could see an eye move towards camera
the focus would would be on that that's
an attention to detail right there that
most people would not catch so I gotta
commend you on that oh well I'm learning
I'm getting better I've been watching
Corridor crew
you've given us the sort of quality that
um to be honest it's as good as anything
that I think we could have got from any
high-end sort of CGI house in Hollywood
I'm sure it's it's that good amazing and
that the the arm break as well to think
outside the box and think of the way to
do it that hasn't been seen before just
fantastic guys I really appreciate it
you've made my film much better so yeah
everybody go check out accident Man 2
you know whether it's on iTunes or you
know streaming service or anything in
Amazon you figured out there's Google
you just type in the word of a thing and
then it shows up it's about a Hitman who
specializes in killing people but making
it look like an accident I feel like
Kung Fu comedy and Gore this is the
movie for you Scott thank you so much uh
next time you're in the states I hope we
get to see you again but uh yeah man
other than that just don't men react
oh yeah